Welcome to the first
Academy Dialogues.
My name is Shawn Finnie from
the Member Relations Department.
Academy Dialogues is a new
series of online conversations
hosted by the Academy.
It begins today with the
Power of Narrative --
a conversation between Academy
Governor Whoopi Goldberg
and civil rights
lawyer Bryan Stevenson,
founder and executive
director of the Equal Justice
Initiative.
They'll be discussing
Hollywood's historic place
as the purveyor of ethnic
and racial stereotypes,
and how the power
of narrative can
become the heart of recovery
by addressing racial, ethnic,
and gender inequities
through the stories
we choose to tell now.
Our first guest needs
little introduction.
Recognized around the world,
actor, performer, activist,
and co-host of ABC
talk show, The View,
where she guides conversation
across American politics,
race relations, popular
culture, and everyday life--
Oscar, Emmy, Grammy,
and Tony Award
winner, and Academy
Governor, Whoopi Goldberg.
Hello.
Our next guest is
Bryan Stevenson.
Bryan is a graduate of
both Harvard Law School
and Harvard's John F.
Kennedy School of Government.
In 1989, he founded the
Equal Justice Initiative
and remains its
executive director.
EJI is based in
Alabama and focuses
on social justice, human rights,
and criminal justice reform
in the United States.
He has argued five cases at
the Supreme Court and won four.
His book, Just Mercy: A Story
of Justice and Redemption
is the basis for the
2019 film, Just Mercy,
that profiles wrongfully
accused death row victim, Walter
McMillan.
Please welcome Bryan Stevenson.
It's great to be with you.
Actually, you want to jump in?
You want to just
jump right into it?
Let's do it.
Well, in listening to all the
things that you've been doing,
I want to know
just from you, how
do you think we got here
at this particular moment?
It's a really
important question,
because I don't think
we've done a very good job
in this country of
educating people
about the history of America.
And we are a country
that has been
corrupted by a history
of racial injustice.
I believe we're not
really free, because we
haven't talked about
the things that
have created this environment.
We have a history
of racial inequality
that is so toxic
that you can still
feel it and see it in the air.
There's a smog in
the atmosphere.
And so I believe
that we really have
to educate ourselves
about the fact
that we're a
post-genocide society.
I think what happened
to Native people
when Europeans came to this
continent was a genocide.
We killed millions
of Indigenous people
through famine and
war and disease,
but we never acknowledge
that violence.
We kept their words-- half the
states in America are Native
words--
but we made those people
leave and we took their land.
We created a
Constitution that talked
about equality and
justice for all,
but excluded these populations.
And that narrative
of racial difference
that we created to
justify that violence
is what then gave rise to 2
and 1/2 centuries of slavery.
And the thing that
I've been trying
to emphasize with people
is that I don't think
the true evil of
American slavery
was involuntary servitude
and forced labor.
I think the real
evil of slavery was
the narrative we created
that Black people aren't
as good as white people, that
Black people aren't fully
human, that Black people
are less deserving, less
evolved, less human.
And that's a terribly
destructive narrative
to create for a
whole race of people.
And we fight the Civil
War, and the 13th Amendment
is passed to end
bondage, but it doesn't
address that fundamental
narrative, that ideology
of white supremacy.
Because of that, I don't
think slavery ends in 1865.
I think it evolves.
And then we see a century
of lynching and terrorism
and segregation and racism
and racial hierarchy.
And we've never really focused
on overcoming that narrative,
confronting this ideology
of white supremacy,
dealing with the
damage created by 400
years of racist thinking.
And because we
haven't done that,
we now live in a moment, where
Black and brown people are
presumed dangerous or guilty.
You can be a talented
Oscar-winning actress or actor,
but if you're Black, you will
go places where you're going
to have to navigate presumptions
of dangerousness and guilt.
And that's why so many people
are out on the streets today,
because when you have
to live like that,
no matter how much
you've accomplished,
no matter what you've done,
how much study you've done --
when you still have to
go places and be presumed
dangerous and guilty because of
your color, it gets exhausting.
You get tired.
And a lot of us are feeling
the weight of that history,
that exhaustion.
And we want things to change.
And I think that's
how we got here.
We got here by being
silent about our history,
about ignoring and
denying the past that
has so fundamentally undermined
and compromised our present.
And that's why I do believe
this is a moment where we're
going to have to reckon
with that history,
talk about Native genocide,
talk about slavery,
talk about lynching,
talk about segregation,
talk about racial inequality,
talk about police violence,
talk about narrative failures
in Hollywood and entertainment.
Talk about all of these things
to create a new understanding
and a new commitment
to what it means
to live in a just society.
Well, one of the
interesting things for me
is whenever I watched
television as a kid,
there were narratives
that were there
that are in me, because
that's what you saw.
So you just assumed,
why would they lie?
Must've been like this.
What wasn't?
And then suddenly, you start
to learn that secondary history
that people don't talk about.
A lot of my friends
who are Italian
have no idea that one of the
largest lynchings in the United
States of America
was of Italians.
My Irish friends, they don't
have a real full understanding
that they too were
looked down upon.
And if we start talking about
the indigenous people here,
these are all narratives that
have been shifted and changed
and moved around.
And it's why adults,
people my age,
kind of look at things and
kind of go, well, where am I?
Where am I in this?
I think people older
than me probably
thought about it, but
not in the same way.
I love surf movies and I never--
we're not even walking
past on the beach.
We're not anywhere near.
Or Where the Boys Are.
Well, where were the boys
that I was looking for?
That's right.
Because we're all going
through the same thing,
but it looks like
we're not present.
That's right.
And those narrative
choices for me
are really important,
because when
you tell a story like that,
when you make a film like that,
you're making choices.
And when you're excluding
whole populations,
you're saying something
about the worth and value
of those populations.
Throughout the first
half of the 20th century,
thousands of Black people were
pulled out of their homes.
They were beaten, they were
drowned, they were hanged,
they were tortured.
And these lynchings
that would sometimes
attract 1,000 or
5,000 white people,
and they would be happening
on the courthouse lawn.
And our law enforcement agencies
and the federal government
said nothing and did nothing.
So when you tell
stories about that era,
and you don't talk
about that phenomenon,
it's almost as if the
lives of Black people
are irrelevant to the first
half of the 20th century.
We made all of these
stories and films --
I grew up watching
these cowboy westerns
and Native people were presented
as villains, as ruthless.
Always.
They never had full
identities and characters.
And we were reinforcing this
narrative of racial difference.
This idea that Native people
and Indigenous people,
they're not like us.
They're not fully human.
They're not to be valued.
And that choice gives
support to this history.
And so now we're
having to reckon
with all of that miseducation.
There are two statutes,
one was in Central Park,
one is outside the
capitol in Alabama,
of this man named Marion Sims.
He was a doctor.
In medical schools, they
frequently refer to him
as the father of gynecology.
And what he did in central
Alabama, in the 1850s,
was experiment on Black women.
Yeah.
He didn't believe that
Black people felt pain.
So he would actually
pull these Black women
and start cutting
on their bodies,
and they would be writhing
and screaming in agony.
And he thought they
were pretending.
And he made these discoveries
about the birth process
that he could then use
and provide some better
outcomes for white women.
Because of those
better outcomes,
he was hailed as
this medical hero.
And there's a statue
of him in Central Park.
There's a statue of him in
front of the Alabama capitol.
Well, the truth is
that he was horrific.
He tortured Black women.
He experimented on Black bodies.
And it was completely
dishonorable what he did.
You cannot honor someone who
did something dishonorable,
so the statue has come
down in Central Park.
But just a few years
ago, that statue
was still outside
of our capitol.
When you begin to
understand these histories,
you think differently
about what's honorable.
And we've honored things in
our films and our stories
and in our TV programming that
we should have never honored.
We should have been
more honest about what
those people represented.
And also, it doesn't
help when you have people
in makeup playing those folks.
And you think to yourself, well,
were there no Native Americans?
You couldn't find anybody?
Jay Silverheels
didn't -- you know?
Because when you start to
tell the narrative as it,
it becomes an imbalance.
Yes.
Because it started out that way.
It's never been a
balanced playing field.
Not ever.
Not for Native Americans,
not for all the Asian folks
who came over to
work in this country.
It's never been
equal or balanced.
And when I look at
what's happening now,
people are saying,
listen, you can tell me
who you think your
heroes are, but I'm
here and been here
long enough to tell you
your heroes may
not be my heroes.
And so I want a part
of the conversation.
And I think that's
what people are doing
and have been doing over the
last 10, 15 years with cinema.
People want to be
present, they want
to be part of this
cinema that's happening
without the sort of ideas
that people have thrown out
from time to time.
Like, well, if you
have a whole bunch
of folks of color in a movie,
it's not gonna sell overseas.
Actually, they do.
I'm a perfect example.
I'm hotter there
than here, you know?
Yeah.
And what people don't
appreciate is -- it's funny,
because it's such
a misguided notion.
In World War I,
when Black soldiers
went to France and Germany,
they were embraced,
they were celebrated.
Black veterans got more
recognition, more applause,
more acknowledgment
for what they
did during World War I
in Europe than they ever
did in this country.
When they came back from World
War I wearing their uniforms,
they were actually
targeted for violence.
And we have a report that
talks about the high rate
of lynchings of Black
veterans after World War I,
because white
Southerners didn't want
them to believe that
they were now somebody
because they had fought.
But their European
experience actually
challenged the idea
that they were less
than their white compatriots.
Same thing happens
in World War II.
And throughout the
1950s and '60s,
actually, Black artists
would go to Europe,
because they felt like
that was a space where they
could avoid or at least
minimize some of the burdens
and barriers.
So this idea that you
can't tell stories
about people of
color that are going
to be embraced or understood
in the international markets
is a very confusing
one when you actually
look at the history of
international and European
responses to the
Black experience.
And I do think it's so
important what you said
about the absence of diversity.
I mean, you couldn't have
made those films about cowboys
and Indians if you had
real Native people on set,
because they would be
challenging these portrayals.
They would complicate
the ease with which
these stories are being told.
And I think so much of that
would be true for Black people,
as well.
And this is funny, because
I talk to my friends,
and they'll say whenever
they see these stories that
are supposed to be about
the experience of women,
I can tell there are no women
involved in that storymaking.
No women were involved
in the creative process,
because the story doesn't ring
true to the lives of women.
And that's why
diversity and inclusion
is such a critical
component of how we begin
changing these narratives.
People talk about diversity,
but a lot of times,
they just want women and
people of color who think
and act just like they
do to be in the room.
They want a different
color to the room,
they want a different
gender to the room,
but they don't want
different thinking.
Yes.
We are not going to
get to the just society
unless we open our minds
and our hearts to the idea
that as things
diversify, things change.
The thinking is going to
change, the conversation is
going to change,
the storytelling is
going to change.
It's going to be more authentic,
and honest, and realistic,
and informed.
And that's the
power of diversity
at this moment in all
sectors, but certainly
in the storytelling sector.
It's an interesting
word, diversity.
Because people
throw it out, they
say, yes, we want to be diverse.
But I don't know that
people really understand
what that actually means.
Because when you say to someone,
well, if you had diversity here
in your newsroom,
someone might have said,
we don't need to watch
another eight minute
segment of this man dying.
Mm-hmm.
Because he's got family.
So where you have people
who are saying, "wait, wait,
we know we're trying
to tell this story,
but we have now shown this
over and over and over
and over and over."
So I need you to figure
out another way for us
to continue to do it.
It's little things and I think
it's little things for women
that women would think of
that a guy just would not.
Yeah.
People of color will recognize
and see, I've seen that,
and we need to do
this differently.
There are just little tweaks
that people can help make.
Why do you think people
are afraid to really have
this conversation?
What is it that really
is scaring people?
Yeah, I think we have
practiced silence
for so long that
when people start
saying the things that you
know haven't been said before,
it unnerves people.
And I do think
people are afraid.
We've got politicians who have
governed through the politics
of fear and anger.
And we've been taught, many
of us, that if that happens,
something bad will
happen to you.
If that happens, something bad--
we got into mass
incarceration in the 1970s
because we had politicians that
were preaching fear and anger.
And they said, we
need a war on drugs
because people who are drug
addicted and drug dependent,
they're dangerous.
We're going to treat
them as criminals.
Now we could have said
that people dealing
with addiction and dependency
have a health problem,
we need a health care response.
We don't have to be afraid--
we just have to be effective.
But that politics of fear
and anger was very powerful.
I think fear and anger are
the essential ingredients
of injustice and inequality.
And we've done a lot of
that in this country.
When you look at the history
of slavery and even the history
of what happened
to Indigenous --
you have to be afraid of
Indigenous people and Native
people, they'll kill you.
You have to be
afraid of Black men,
they'll do all of
these terrible things.
It was this fear of full
equality that shaped that,
and that's why those lynchings
were so powerful and potent.
We can't let our children
go to school with Black kids
because that wouldn't
be safe and healthy.
And I think that as
we begin now to tell
the truth about this history,
we have to just have courage.
It's interesting when you think
about the elements of therapy,
whether you're dealing
with addiction, alcoholism,
drug addiction, whatever -- the
first thing you have to do is
to be willing to tell the
truth about who you are.
12 steps works,
only works, when you
are prepared to say, "I'm an
alcoholic, I'm an addict."
And then you begin to tell
the truth of what that means
in your life, and
that truth telling
is an essential
part of the process.
And what we have to have the
courage to have in this country
is to admit that we are a nation
shaped by racism and bigotry.
We are a post-genocide society.
We've done horrific things.
We were a slave society.
We were a society that
perpetrated racial terrorism.
The Black people that are
in the North and the West
are consequences of
this era of terror.
Between 1900 and 1950,
millions of Black people
fled the American South.
And we haven't
acknowledged the fact
that the Black people
in Cleveland and Chicago
and Detroit and Los Angeles and
Oakland and New York and Boston
didn't go to those communities
as immigrants looking
for new economic opportunities.
They went to those communities
as refugees and exiles
from terror in the
American South.
And we haven't talked about it.
And so all the Black
people come up to me
and they say "Mr.
Stevenson, I get angry
when I hear somebody
say that we're
dealing with domestic
terrorism for the first time
in our nation's
history after 9/11."
They say, "we grew
up with terror.
We have to worry about being
bombed and lynched and menaced
every day of our life."
And because we have
this fear that if we're
honest about the past, it'll
be painful and difficult,
we try to avoid it.
But the reality is, is what
every therapeutic intervention
that's effective
that I know tells
us is that it's only when we're
honest that we get better.
It's through truth-telling
that we can actually
begin to understand how to
cope with our addictions,
our dependency, our abuse.
I mean, an abuse --
a lot of time for the first
half of the 20th century,
said people who were sex
abuse victims and child abuse
victims should never talk about
it, and that's not healthy.
So I think that's what we have
to get people to understand --
is that if we have the
courage to tell the truth --
I mean, I'm from a faith
tradition, in my church,
you can't just
walk in and say, "I
want heaven and all
that good stuff,
I want all of that
redemption and salvation."
They'll tell you, well,
you first have to repent.
You have to confess.
You cannot be afraid to tell
the truth of what you've done
and who you are.
Once you do that,
on the other side
is redemption and
restoration and uplift
and all of these things.
And part of what I'm
trying to do in our work
is to tell people,
I don't want to talk
about the Native genocide
and slavery and lynching
and segregation because
I want to punish America.
I want to talk
about these things
because I want to liberate us.
I want us to get
to something else.
And I really believe
that there's something
better waiting for us.
I think there is
something that feels more
like freedom, that feels more
like equality, that feels more
like justice.
There are better
movies to be made.
stories to be told.
There's a kind of future
for this industry that
energizes all people, because
it tells all of those stories.
But to get there,
we're going to have
to be honest about the
ways we have failed,
the ways we have
undermined truth telling,
and then give truth to that.
And for me, truth and
justice is sequential.
People want to skip
to the reconciliation,
they want to skip
to the reparation
without telling the truth.
It doesn't work like that.
It's only when we
tell the truth that we
have a consciousness that
allows us to repair the damage,
to restore confidence, to
build healthy relationships.
And I'm going to
ask this question,
and I hope it's taken in
the spirit that I ask it.
What do we need
to help people --
white people -- understand?
Because I feel like white
people are very nervous.
Yeah.
They're very nervous.
Because sometimes, I feel
like, you should know this.
I should not be walking
you through this.
And then I realize that
unless a lot of this
has touched you in
your life, you're
not going to be thinking
about it the way that I am.
You're not going to
notice where I am not.
Yeah.
So what can we do to help people
who are not people of color?
Who are not women?
Who are white
people or white men?
How do we help them
walk through this storm?
Because it is a storm.
Yeah.
Well, this is where I think
actually Hollywood and film
and media have a
critical role to play,
because what this
industry can do,
which very few industries
can do, is to invite people
into a space, and in
a couple of hours,
tell a story that radically
shifts their thinking.
And I've seen it, just because
my book was turned into a movie
--
movie came out in January --
I've gotten thousands and
thousands of emails and letters
from people who were saying,
"I'm a 57-year-old white man,
I'm a 70 --
I did not understand
the problems
that were being created
by our criminal justice."
And they desperately now
want to do something.
And they just saw a movie, and
then they want to read a book,
and now they want
to see other things.
Storytelling is a powerful
way to invite people
into a conversation that
wouldn't ordinarily get there.
And we've done it
over and over again.
I think about domestic
violence for example.
And your question,
Whoopi, about white men,
it's a particularly
compelling one.
You know, we didn't
have a healthy attitude
about women who
were experiencing
violence in the home.
Throughout most of
the '60s and '70s,
we were indifferent
to that victimization.
We blamed people for
being in relationships
where they were being abused.
We joked about
domestic violence.
There used to be a show -- you
remember The Jackie Gleason
Show, at the end of that show,
he'd say, "to the moon, Alice."
And everybody would laugh.
And that threat of
violence wasn't something
that we saw problematic.
Right.
And then we started telling
stories that actually took
the perspective of abused
women, and Farrah Fawcett
made that movie,
The Burning Bed,
she played the role of that.
And then all of a sudden,
people who were being abused
started lifting their
voices, and the narrative
began to shift.
And you could no longer
ignore the pain and anguish
and suffering connected
to that kind of violence
and victimization.
Mothers Against Drunk
Driving organized in the '80s
to create a new relationship
to driving while drunk.
We didn't punish people who
were intoxicated while driving.
Depending on their
status, we might not even
arrest them or
give them a ticket.
We didn't deal with it.
But when Mothers
Against Drunk Driving
started using narrative
to tell painful stories
about the children they lost
because of our inability
to confront that problem,
the narrative shifted.
And today, we're seeing
the consequences of that.
You can be a celebrity
or athlete --
if there's a credible
allegation of domestic violence,
you are going to be
held accountable in ways
that you would not have
been held accountable
even 10 years ago.
And that's a narrative shift.
We wouldn't have marriage
equality in this country
if we hadn't started
telling stories
that got people who didn't
want to hear about same sex
relationships to now be in
stories where that became
a part of it.
And that's why I think that
Hollywood has a critical role
to play in addressing this
long history of silence
about racial inequality,
this long history of silence
about racism and bigotry
and racial hierarchy.
I look at the catalog
of films and stories
that we have about the
Holocaust, which are so vital.
We need more of them, because
clearly, anti-Semitism
is still a problem.
We have a whole
catalog of stories.
And I've seen a hundred
films about that experience
and I want to see more,
but we have so few
in the catalog of
films and storytelling
about the brutality of
slavery, about the era
of lynching, about the pain
and suffering of segregation.
And I think until we
fix that, until we
correct that, these are
American stories that have never
been told.
We just put out a report about
Reconstruction in America --
horrific time.
Between 1865 and 1876, 2,000
Black people are lynched,
lawlessness reigns.
The federal government
retreats from helping
formerly enslaved people.
It's probably the most
critical 12 year period
in American history and
you can't count on one hand
the number of committed
narratives, films, stories,
programs that have dealt
honestly with that era.
And until we fix that --
and I think that's
what we can do.
I think we can invite reluctant
cautious viewers and people who
don't want to, to
step into a space,
and then hear some things
and see some things
and live through the
characters in ways that
get them to come out
on the other side
now in a different place.
I've seen it happen
with Just Mercy.
I saw it happen with
The Color Purple.
I remember seeing The
Color Purple in the South,
and there were people all
around me, white viewers,
who were very hesitant.
They were told it
was a great movie,
but they weren't so
sure if they wanted.
And, you know, there
were those scenes,
and they were crying
just like everybody else
at the end of that film.
And it changed their
perspective on what
it meant to live in that
region with this population
of Black people who were
marginalized and excluded
and oppressed.
And that's the power of
effective storytelling.
And that's why I do think
Hollywood has a critical role
to play in addressing that very
problem that you articulate,
which is how do we get the
people who are very hesitant,
who are reluctant.
We get to them by going to
their spaces, their living
rooms, their movie
theaters, the places where
they consume entertainment.
And getting them exposed
to these realities.
And is it also making
people aware of --
we have a lot of movies
about American history.
We have a ton of movies
But it's only half of the story.
It's only a quarter
of the story.
All of these amazing films
that people have made from time
immemorial, from the very
first Lincoln in Illinois
to the newest Lincoln
that was made.
This is a big portion
of American history.
But there are other portions of
American history that you also
need to know in order not to
recreate them in real life.
Is that a way to help
people understand
that these stories are ours?
They're not Black stories
-- they're American stories.
It's like making 50
films about World War II
and never addressing
the Holocaust.
It's incomplete.
It almost becomes
dishonest to make films
about the battles and the
soldiers fighting on the field
and never acknowledge or
mention the Holocaust.
It's just dishonest.
And we've done that in America
with a lot of our storytelling.
We'll tell stories about
mid-19th century history
and never talk about slavery.
Or do it in such a
marginal way that it
seems as some peripheral issue.
And that's what you're seeing
in the stories you hear,
that's what you think.
We tell stories
about World War I,
we tell stories about the
first half of the 20th century
as if we're living
in this place where
there isn't all of this
terror and violence going on.
And so yes, I do
think it becomes
dishonest to tell these
stories without being
open to and committed
to acknowledging
all the elements of it.
And I just think again,
a lot of storytelling
is what do people want to hear.
We're only going
to tell the stories
that people want to hear and
that's how we make money.
If we just give
people what they want.
But when you look at
the film industry,
we have actually
rejected that many times.
People started
making movies that
pushed back against the
bigotry toward LGBTQ people.
We started making movies that
pushed back against this idea
that women were just
ornaments in the household.
And it was courageous,
but it was necessary,
and it ultimately was very
effective, and very successful.
And now I actually think
there's a real hunger
to understand the
world in which we live.
We have to match that appetite
with the kind of storytelling
--
I do think as an advocate,
I know I can't go
into a courtroom, and just
demand things, and say,
I want this, and I believe --
I've got to go where people are.
Yeah.
But I go there with a mission.
Of leading them to some
place I think we all
need to be that's healthier.
And that's why we're doing a
lot of the work that we do.
We have a project
where we're actually --
we have memos that talk
about white Southerners that
were abolitionists that
tried to end slavery.
We have a memo that talks
about white Southerners that
were opposed to
lynching and tried
to prevent these instances
of racial terror.
There are white people
who were actually working
to end racial segregation.
And if I took that memo and
read out some of those names,
mostly nobody in the country
would know any of those names.
Yeah.
And I'm saying to folks we don't
have to make false monuments
to people who experimented
on Black women mercilessly
or people who perpetrated and
defended slavery or people who
were violent misogynists -- we
don't have to have monuments
to them to have a history
that we can be proud of.
There are these other people
who did these honorable things,
and that's the kind of thing
that storytelling can do.
The film about the Black women
who participated in the NASA
launch with John Glenn --
that story was made
and new characters
were introduced to the
American consciousness.
It has a profound
impact on how we
think about the lives of
Black women and the value
that Black women can
bring to everything.
But without those stories,
that doesn't happen.
And also, we're talking about
World War I and World War II,
and when you think about how
many folks of color fought
in both of those wars, came
home and could not walk
on the sidewalk --
for me, if you're going to tell
the history of World War II,
there were a lot of people
fighting in World War II.
There were a lot of
people who discovered what
was going on in Nazi Germany.
And several of the
Black details were
the guys who first walked
into places like Auschwitz.
This is a story that's
never been told.
We are in a way, held apart.
Like we weren't there,
we weren't fighting.
And I feel like a lot
of what is happening
is young folks don't really
know the history because they
think of it as being
something so long ago.
They're not aware of our
part in this country.
Or the Native Americans'
part in this country, what
these folks did, what we did to
fight for a nation that did not
have enough time to show
us a modicum of respect.
And in fact, hung us because
they were mad that we're
wearing medals and stuff.
So those conversations,
those films.
And those are important
and need to be done.
They need to be done.
There's a great book called
Destined to Witness--
Growing up Black
in Nazi Germany.
Extraordinary book.
And we had it for a while, and
when we'd bring it to people,
people would say,
well, what's the hook?
It's like, OK, OK.
Because it's like if you
can't figure out the hook,
I don't know how to
explain it to you.
Or you want to say,
hey, there's a lot
to be learned from Black
performers in the earlier
part of the century.
There's a lot to be learned
from Native American comics.
I mean, there's just Asian
comics and Latin comics,
and we are all here trying
to tell these stories.
And how do we get these
conversations going and get
past the verbiage
that makes it sound --
it sounds good, but you know
that nothing's going to happen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's really in the
richness of the narrative.
And you just characterized
it so wonderfully.
All of these stories, you
have hundreds of thousands
of Black people who go
fight for an America
that won't let them
vote, that won't
let them go through
the front door, that
won't respect their basic
dignity, that won't pay them
fairly.
But they put on a
uniform to go fight
for that nation with
the hope that if they
show courage and bravery,
they'll be accepted.
And then they come
back and they get
to the train
station in some town
where white people will
say, "take that uniform off,
because you don't deserve it."
And they're humiliated
by these mobs.
And we tell the stories of all
of these Black veterans that
are lynched and beaten
and abused because they
keep their uniform on.
And there's so much important
drama and important truth
telling in a story like that
that we haven't explored,
we haven't talked about.
You talk about the Native
contributions, the Code
Breakers and all of that,
and we'll hint at it,
but we haven't actually dealt
honestly with that legacy,
as well.
And I think part of it
is truth can be powerful.
Overcoming obstacles can
be powerful, no matter what
your background is.
A story about perseverance,
a story about people
who have courage, who stand
up when everybody says
sit down, who speak when
everybody says be quiet--
a story like that
can inspire everybody
and not just people who
are part of that community.
And we haven't actually
tapped in to the power
of storytelling, the power of
inspirational storytelling.
The power of these
incredible stories
by denying or not allowing
ourselves to tell stories
about this community
or that community
or these kinds of
difficult topics.
And I just think that's got
to be part of the equation.
We've got to have the
courage of our convictions.
But because Hollywood
and story filmmakers
are responsible for a
lot of the false ideas,
a lot of the bigotry, a lot
of that racial hierarchy,
I think we have an
obligation to do it.
And to be courageous
and to push it.
And I just think that's got
to be part of the mix, too.
I came up -- again --
my faith tradition is
to whom much is given,
much is required.
Hollywood, this industry,
has as a central platform
across the globe.
We all love movies, we all love
stories, we all love engaging.
And that's an opportunity
to do some things.
And I just think with
that opportunity,
with all of those
resources and spaces,
we have an obligation to
kind of push some things.
And I don't think we should
think about it as corruptive
or anything like that.
I just think it's truth telling.
I'm seeing these
new sets of stories
about challenging the
way people in Hollywood
were targeted during
the McCarthy era.
And there is a narrative now
about the victimization that
took place by the excess
of government oversight
and bigotry.
And when you begin
to understand it,
it positions you
differently when
people start making unfair
judgments about people
in this industry today.
And building that
consciousness is
how we protect ourselves from
repeating the sins of the past.
And I just think we haven't
done that enough when
it comes to racism,
when it comes to bias.
The beautiful thing about all
that wonderful storytelling
around the Holocaust --
I go to the Holocaust
museum, it's so powerful.
At the end of it, I'm
motivated to say, never again.
I look for cultural
spaces that talk honestly
about the history of slavery
and lynching and segregation
and I can't find them.
Until we create those spaces
and we create those stories that
motivate us at the end to say,
never again can we tolerate
this kind of
bigotry, we're going
to be vulnerable to the problems
that we're seeing today.
I look around and I think,
"where are the LGBTQ stories?"
Where are those stories,
which we need to know,
because people know who they
are when they're little.
So why aren't we supporting
that and allowing films
to be made that will help
young people through?
That will give us some other
visual of the LGBTQ community
other than as the comic relief?
Yeah.
These are really
important, and I always
get in trouble, because
people always say,
well, you never include women.
I do include women, but I
don't include all women.
Because for me, there
was always someone who
was going to win Best Actress.
Always, she was
always going to win.
But Hattie McDaniel was the
first one of color to win,
and she won Best Supporting.
But women excelled -- white
women seem to have had an upper
hand for the longest time.
But even as we look at that,
as we see what we've had to pay
for, because there are not a
whole bunch of female directors
or producers --
and there should be.
There should be, given how
many women we're working
in the '20s, '30s, '40s, '50s--
there should be a
plethora and there's not.
So clearly, there is a problem.
And this is one of the
things I've been pushing --
I think institutions and
industries like the film
industry could gain something
making a formal commitment
to truth-telling So
we're going to actually
have a period of
time where we're
going to create a process,
where we're going to just
be honest about the ways that
we failed to confront racism.
We failed to confront
truth telling
from the experience of LGBTQ.
And you can point
to a whole catalog
of films that really
perpetrated a kind of violence
against these communities by
the way they told stories.
And I think it's worth
talking about that.
I actually don't think
it's a waste of time
to engage in that
kind of reflection
and the barriers
that were created,
that barred opportunities
for women directors and women
producers and producers
and directors of color.
You had to be so exceptional
and so extraordinary
to have any chance at
all to direct a film
if you're a Black person.
All of those things are things
I think we can talk about
and should talk
about, because once
we put it all out there--
the truth and reconciliation
process in South Africa was
critical to that nation's
recovery from apartheid.
And victims of apartheid
could come in and speak
what happened to them.
It would be
emotional, but it made
them feel differently
about the future
that they had that opportunity.
And the perpetrators had
to speak to that, as well.
And Rwanda, after
the genocide, they
recognized that
they couldn't heal
if they didn't create
a process for people
to talk honestly about the
pain and suffering of seeing
your whole family or your
whole village slaughtered.
And then for perpetrators
to give voice
to what was going
through their head,
it allowed people
to feel differently.
I look at Germany today,
and I wouldn't go to Germany
if they didn't
acknowledge the Holocaust.
If they weren't committed.
And you can't go
200 meters in Berlin
without seeing markers
and stones that
had been placed next to the
homes of Jewish families
that were abducted
during the Holocaust.
There's that beautiful
Holocaust memorial
in the center of Berlin, and
cab drivers and hotel operators
encourage you to go there.
Every police officer
in Germany has
to go to the Holocaust sites.
Every student has to go.
There are no Adolf Hitler
statues in Germany.
It would be unconscionable
for someone to say--
That is not there.
Exactly.
It's not waving and people
aren't flying over there.
In fact, the swastika is banned.
Yes.
The Nationalist movement that
is trying to emerge there,
they're using the
Confederate flag
from America as their temple.
But the idea that they would
have a monument to an architect
of the Third Reich.
It's so unconscionable.
But you come to this
country and our landscape
is littered with the
iconography of the defenders
and perpetrators of slavery.
That's a function of the truth
telling we have failed to do.
And that's, to me,
the beauty of this --
is that on the
other side of this,
something really
extraordinary can happen.
So they are telling
me that we're
moments away from
questions, which
I'm excited to see and hear.
I'm not sure how
that's going to work.
I think Shawn is going
to put questions up
that people may have.
So while I'm waiting
for that, I will ask,
are you optimistic
about the future, truly?
I am, I am.
And for me, being hopeful is a
necessary element of this work.
I think hopelessness is
the enemy of justice,
because when you become
hopeless, you accept it.
You don't fight, you
don't tolerate things.
I think injustice prevails
where hopelessness persists.
So for me, it's an
orientation, it's
an obligation to stay hopeful.
But I'm genuinely hopeful,
because I'm seeing some things
that I haven't seen before.
I'm seeing this broad
coalition of people
speaking about these issues.
I'm seeing companies
responding to this.
Even from five years ago.
I'm seeing the things that I
didn't see in 2015 and 2014,
and that encourages me.
But yeah, I am hopeful.
And I live in
Montgomery, Alabama
and it's hard to
not be hopeful when
you think about the
generation that came before,
and you've been here, and
you've made that amazing movie
about the boycott.
But when I think about the Black
folks in this community who
did so much more with so much
less, a community of people who
didn't have legal
institutions to protect them,
who didn't have
money to get bail,
that didn't have
all of these things.
And yet they would put
on their Sunday best,
and they would go places and
demand the right to vote,
and fight for the right
to be treated fairly.
And they knew they'd get
bloodied and battered
and beaten, but
they went anyway.
When I think about the
kind of courage that took,
I realize that I'm standing
on their shoulders.
Absolutely.
Standing on their shoulders.
I don't have the choice
to say, this is too hard,
this is too much,
I got to give up.
I just feel like it is an
obligation to keep fighting.
And so yes, I am hopeful
about what we can do,
and about what we can
achieve in this moment.
I just want to keep pushing.
I want to make sure it's not
a moment, but a movement.
That we actually begin
a process where 12 years
from now, we can
say, look at what
we've done over
the last 12 years
to get to a different place.
That's what I'd love to see.
I'd love to see a whole catalog
of films and stories and movies
12 years from now that
you and I could point to,
this new body of work that
has helped us get people
to understand the
challenges that we face.
One of the great things about
all of this as people are --
and we would talk
about being woke --
I say you may be woke now
-- that's because we let you
sleep.
Yeah, that's right.
So now everybody's up, and
the key is we have to stay up.
We have to stay on top of this.
And this is going
to be slow going.
It's not an easy thing to do.
But I feel like people are
open to the conversation.
They're open to hearing
how can I make it better.
"What, I need to change
the name of the team?"
Yes, you do.
Yes.
And seeing that was, like, OK,
something clearly is happening.
That's right.
Because it's always been
clear to some of us that
that's an offensive name,
but to... recognize it,
that's good.
But it is encouraging.
Yeah.
But it's nice to hear that
they say they want to stop.
So Shawn, I see that you
are about to jump on this.
I am here, Whoopi.
Thank you, Whoopi
and Bryan, both.
This is such an
amazing conversation.
Literally could
listen for hours.
I want to get to some
of our member questions.
OK.
The first one is
for the both of you.
How can we at the Academy
collect and present evidence,
not just words,
but actual numbers,
to the media
financiers that films
with Black, brown,
LGBTQ casts and stories
do not inhibit good box office?
Well, it seems to me
you have to show people.
You have enough
evidence that people
are interested in these
stories, because they
are the universal stories.
These are not
specific to America.
These are not just
American stories.
These are stories that exist
everywhere in the world.
And you put
everything else out, I
don't know why you
wouldn't take a shot
on some of these stories.
I'm sorry, Bryan.
No, no, no --
as something of a bit
of an outsider on this,
I am struck by why there has to
be this higher burden of proof
when it comes to the value
of these other stories.
Black Panther made more money
than any Marvel film before it.
It smashed records, it
was an international hit.
And yet there's
still the skepticism,
because people just have a hard
time reconciling themselves
with this reality.
That the films that have
had critical success,
films like Moonlight, films like
12 Years a Slave are stories
that ordinarily, you'd see a lot
of people trying to replicate
that, because they want that
same critical success --
or that same kind of
financial success.
But it's almost as if the
industry sometimes says,
oh, well, we did
Black Panther, so we
don't have to do anything again
for another five or 10 years.
Or we did that film.
And I think that's
really the problem.
I don't think it's a finance
proof number as much as it's
an orientation number.
These are American stories.
If we want to tell
the story of America,
we have to tell all
of these stories.
And there's never been a
shortage or an unwillingness
to tell an American
story, but we just
have to now open that lens.
I mean, I think
the data is there.
But more than the
data, I just think
there has to be an orientation
that these stories have value.
Yes, they have value
at the box office,
but they have even
broader value beyond that.
And can I add something to that?
Because it would
also be helpful if
people recognized who
is inhabiting the world.
It's not like we're
not everywhere.
We are all over the world.
You'd be surprised to find out
how many different ethnicities
that look like all the
ethnicities you see here
are living all over the world.
So these stories,
they are connected.
And if we make them,
we'll know if they work
and how well they work.
It's somebody has
got to make the step.
Thank you both.
The next question is
for the both of you --
do you believe that it is more
or less difficult for Black
or people of color,
filmmakers, to break into genre
filmmakers-- example, rom-coms
or sci-fi, fantasy, action,
et cetera?
I don't know, because --
ask Jordan Peele.
He seems to make the
movies he wants to make.
The question is, is there money?
Are there giant bags
of money someplace
for filmmakers who
want to do that?
I feel that's been a lot
of filmmakers' problems,
because if you go to some of
the bigger places, they say,
well, we have to own everything.
You are already in deep
doo before you even start,
because you're just
trying to get some money
to make your movie.
If it was as
prevalent as it seems
to be for some
many other folks, I
think that would answer that
question better than I could.
Money is what is at the root
of getting stuff made, I feel.
And can I just add --
I actually think when you look
at the history of film making
and storytelling in America
throughout the 20th century,
the industry failed to
actually invite voices in
to tell complete
stories, to tell
truthful stories about our
experience in this country.
And when you have
failed, and you
didn't do what you
were supposed to do,
you should want to repair that.
You should want to remedy that.
And you should actually
make it a commitment
to invest in corrections to
that, and let that lead you.
I just don't think that we
should assume that the playing
field is level
now and we're just
going to see used the same
tactics and strategy that we
used before.
In the 1960s --
what we've done in
this country when
it comes to justice
and rights, it's
like it's different than what
we do in other areas of the law.
In law school, I
had to study damages
for tort violations and
contract violations, corporate.
There's trouble damages
and punitive damages.
We have a very
elaborate construct
of what people are
obligated to pay when they
have violated someone's rights.
But in the human rights, in
the civil rights context,
it's almost as if we
say all we want to do
is to stop violating
their rights
and you don't have
to do anything else.
And I think that's left
us vulnerable to failing
to appreciate our obligations
to do more to repair
the damage that we did.
I think in 1965, after
these states denied
Black people the right
to vote for 100 years,
states like Alabama
and Mississippi
should have just been told,
"you can't do that anymore."
I actually think
that Black people
should have been
automatically registered
to vote in those states.
I don't think that
would have been wrong.
It would have been repair
for the damage that was done.
I don't think it would've
been wrong to say
to the University of
Georgia and Mississippi,
you've got to let Black
kids who are qualified
to attend these universities,
attend for free,
because you have to do something
to repair the damage that you
did by excluding Black
people for so long.
And so this industry, I think --
it would not be wrong
for this industry
to say, "we're going to commit
a percentage of our resources
to create platforms
for Black storytellers,
and producers, and directors
and, people of color,
and people whose voices have
been historically excluded."
Because we now want
to say to the world
that we want to fix the
problem that we helped
sustain by our silence.
And with that kind
of orientation,
we can make it easier for
directors and producers
and storytellers of color
to have an opportunity
to tell their stories.
And what we'll get from that are
some amazingly talented people
becoming some of our leaders
and some of the legends
that we all want to
be in these spaces.
I don't think that's
the wrong orientation --
I think it could actually
be a healthy orientation
for the industry.
That's a great idea, too.
Thank you.
Next question --
we have two more --
Just Mercy -- this
is for you, Bryan.
Just Mercy resonates with
our experiences with access
to justice in my
homeland, Kenya.
How do we get the
critics on board
so that they highlight
diverse stories?
It's interesting --
I don't know how to do --
I think one of the things
that was fascinating to me,
and I didn't understand
this, and Whoopi probably
had this experience
much more than I have,
is that the people who were
judging the film initially
were people who knew very little
about the lived experience.
It's like we played the
film and Black audiences
and white audiences
were responding
with such enthusiasm.
You look at the cinema
score for a film like that,
it's through the roof.
But critics all went,
we've seen this before.
And I was, like, well,
where have you seen this?
I don't recall any films
that actually talk --
I didn't see it before.
I never met a lawyer until
I got to Harvard Law School,
so a story of Black people
just surrounded by lawyers,
that wasn't familiar to me.
And I think there is a
sort of cynicism about it.
I remember when The
Color Purple came out,
I remember reading a review
in the Atlanta Constitution
by a well-known reviewer
and what they said,
well, they didn't
like parts of film.
They said it was unfair
to the white people.
There were no white
heroes in this.
They didn't present
white people.
And it's that kind
of orientation
that I think we
have to confront.
There's a critical perspective
in this country that
is shaped by these
same narratives
that we've been talking about
during this conversation.
We have to understand that.
And I think people
need to be called out.
I remember writing-- that was
the first time I ever wrote
a letter to a film critic --
is when I read that review
about The Color Purple --
it wasn't fair to the white.
As if somehow white people
were doing everything
they possibly could in the
first half of the 20th century
to help Black people escape
the ravages of sharecropping
and tenant farming?
If anything, it
understated multiple ways
in which a white bias
and Jim Crow laws
could create that
kind of narrative.
And I just think part
of it is shifting
who has that platform,
just like we need
a more diverse
community of people
making films and producing
films and starring in films,
we need a more diverse platform
of people who are evaluating
these films and they
can speak to the value
of the storytelling.
And I think that's part of it.
And I'm glad to hear
that somebody from Kenya
is here, because I do think
these stories are global.
I've been to Africa
and seeing the way
in which access to justice can
be a problem in that society.
When you hear a story about how
you can overcome that and maybe
succeed, that's
inspiring for everybody.
I've gotten some
beautiful letters
from people in East
Africa in response
to seeing the film that
I was really moved by.
And that's the power of
effective storytelling.
Thank you so much, Bryan.
And our last question is,
we are poor at teaching
our history of discrimination.
While docs -- documentaries
-- are a good start,
how do we encourage filmmakers
to eschew creating distorted
history or social views in
the name of creative choice?
I'm gonna let you
do this one, Bryan.
You know, it's funny --
I think most
filmmakers don't want
to present a story
that they know is going
to be exposed as false, right?
So I was in a movie
theater one time
and they had a character in
Mobile, Alabama and the actor
said, I'm going to
Mobile, Alabama.
And the whole theater started
laughing and a bunch of people
left because they
couldn't trust a film that
didn't get that right.
And so if we really
want to be honest,
if we don't want to expose
ourselves as just being
completely --
then I think we have to be
willing to tell the full story.
And I often think
that filmmakers have
one kind of viewer in mind.
That's a certain person
of a certain race
of a certain
demographic group as
if America is only that person.
And as Whoopi said,
we're going to soon
be a minority majority country.
There will be more people
of color in this country
than there are people
who identify as white.
And I just think
when you step back
and say, let me think about
how young kids of color
are going to
experience this story
or how women are going
to experience this,
then you begin to understand
that these so-called creative
choices kind of make it easy
and comfortable for people
are things that we
should push back.
The most effective films
that I've ever seen,
the most moving
films are the films
that at times made me
uncomfortable, because that's
what good storytelling does.
It actually pushes you.
It actually exposes
you to a thing.
It's not just
something that you take
to make you feel good at night.
It's sometimes the most powerful
filmmaking can push you.
We cannot create more justice,
we cannot create a healthier
society if we're unwilling to
do things that are uncomfortable
and inconvenient.
And powerful films--
I think about films
like Schindler's List.
At times, it's so
uncomfortable and so painful.
You're worried about
what's going to happen.
You know, great films --
Fruitvale Station, my friend,
Ryan Coogler's film --
difficult, challenging.
But those are the
kinds of stories
that ultimately stay with you.
I can remember those
scenes, even though I
saw the film 20 years ago.
If you want to make
memorable film making that
makes a difference, that lasts,
that endures the test of time,
then we have to be
willing to tell the truth.
We have to be willing
to do the hard things,
even if they're uncomfortable
and inconvenient.
And I think that ought to be the
norm rather than the exception.
And I think Hollywood
and the big studios
have to keep reinforcing
their interest
in that kind of storytelling
by investing in films that
tell those stories, and not
just the simple easy stories
that you can forget about an
hour or two after you leave
the theater.
I also think that it would
behoove folks who wanted
to tell these stories who may
not be Native American or Black
folks -- they may be white
people who are just invested
in the story --
team up with folks so that we
can help you get them right.
We can help you get
to the place where
you want your story to be.
I believe we can do this
as a coalition of artists,
because that's what we are.
We're artists, whether we're
hair artists or light artists,
we are all artists in this.
And together, we can
make huge differences.
But we've got to cop to
the stuff we don't know.
Talk about the stuff
that really pisses us off
that we don't understand.
And listen, I'm not perfect.
I know I have all kinds of
tendencies to snap in my mind
when I see somebody and
they become that so and so.
We all have these
tendencies, and so we
have to fight through them
and talk about the fact
that we have them,
and then move forward.
I think we can only do it
kind of collectively, I think,
really.
Yeah.
Bryan and Whoopi Goldberg, thank
you both so much for joining,
for sharing your truth, your
transparency, your lights
with all of us.
To our members who
have been attending
from around the world, to
the board of governors,
and to the incredible Academy
staff who put this together,
this is just the
beginning of what
we hope to be a long lasting
fruitful conversation
about change.
Thank you for hosting our
first Academy Dialogues.
We are better because
of the both of you.
Thank you so very much.
Thank you.